estamos aqui agora com um cast one qat
não há assim uma funciona ao sion na
suíça que foi pouco para que o meio é
estranho é muito amor mas o banco havia
chamado de donna a mãe de amanda que
agora a gente está esperando assim
trazemos dólar se lembra daquele
encontro de fãs que a gente fez aqui em
teresina fim com distância eu pediria
leva lá onde estava todo mundo levou o
que a gente fez gente pegou esse
dinheiro enquanto fãs
mandamos fazer comandamos não a galera
do projeto ele mandou fazer uns ovos é
isso for pegar os jogos agora e agora a
gente tá empregar esses ovos partida do
teatro todo tinha andado do fonatur vou
esperar ele chegar com os ovos estão
chegando com os ovos a gente chegar com
os jogos a gente partiu o campeonato e
vamos pegar os ovos 4 à noite chegou
2014 e tem que fazer a doação para
decidir o nome de deus né porque tem
gente que faz as conhecia vamos fazer
porque quando chegar no céu deus vai
falar num tragando off as criancinhas em
que bonfá que eu acho assim era a vida a
vida é uma carta de baralho
se você faz um castelo de baixo você
tira uma peça o castelo todo caio então
é mais ou menos isso aí você não adianta
você construir muita coisa por vocês
guarda coisa pra você você não ajuda
ninguém acha que não vale nada
então a gente vai lá e se tornou hoje a
galera diz ainda que estamos aqui na
pracinha e também no de pé mesmo lá para
o negócio estou aqui pra mostrar pra
vocês que eu sou muito ativa
estamos gravando indo para 1
eu não consigo falar em cinema foi a
trilha é o pt que indicará quem vai fazê
la
fala galera legal de papo para as
crianças brincar com ela foi obrigada a
fazer um negócio vamos fazer boas ações
ganhou bolo de natal é só explicar para
vocês que estão assistindo que não pode
filmar lá dentro então não vai ter mais
agilidade dentro mas eu quero registrar
esse momento que a gente está indo a
mostrar os jogos também mostrará mostrar
tudo
acho que na festa mostrado após uma hora
e também de mostrar coisas
no mesmo livro que ela mesmo manda
gabriela tabela estamos aqui fazendo
boas ações contra sertaneja você não vai
ganhar pontos com deus gosta ou tem
agora a falar e se muito mais um caminho
mais duro aguentar no domingo e aí acho
que a f 1000 vez que a gente tá aí num
europa nada patrício pt-df transporta
ela é isso aí vamos lá daqui a pouco vou
mostrar os jogos pra vocês acham que
aconteceu agora é só você ver como o
mundo gentileza gera gentileza gente
está em fazer boas razões e entrega o
ovo de páscoa apareceu uma alma caridosa
e ofereceu esse é o brasil que vai
sediar a copa e estou aqui os dois hoje
parece que nem um pouco
a gente vai fazendo caixa os jogos a
gente vai esconder jogos a gente volte
por essa questão pelo litígio com o
shakhtar bem melhor do que aqueles que
têm nas vendas
esse que chocolate tamanho melhor fica
para nós a isso
pena que ninguém dê você sai com nené e
está todo o dinheiro do encontro ao
apontar os mais um dia negativo o verão
aqui é um grande problema que a
assistência de todos os bichos primeira
vez no domingo jogando desvirginada
disse que vai agitar para cima tudo
quem vai ganhar um pouquinho
ele vai pegar minha filha hoje com a
vitória fechou a orientação da galera eu
sou um pré olímpico não tem orelhas
porque eu fui maltratado por caçadores
ai eu tentei correr tentei tentei tentei
me livrar dos caçadores não conseguiram
acabaram levando a minha orelha e hoje
eu sou um fenômeno que pode estacionar
em qualquer lugar que eu sonho com um
déficit dessa minha vida e eu consegui
passar no vestibular e eto'o superação é
botar ovos de ouro pintada de chocolate
a semente história de quando era toda a
página
ae
pois é a galera acha que acabou de sair
já que o negócio foi muito massa e
vettel já tô eita que beleza aqui é como
é que eu tô que liga o estado e as
crianças deixa a pessoa onde criança
agora de crença de marbella dormir não
amo muito
op conectar a gente cantou mt luan
santana elas ficarem pecado que disseram
alguém disse que eu fui com scat a
regina casé meu deus muito boa gente a
sensação de dever cumprido sabe é que
você tá aqui ó romaria é muito bom e
espero que vocês tenham gostado também
foi bem bacana bem da hora mesmo queria
muito agradecer a vocês que muito
agradeço a vocês que foi no encontro que
doará que lhe revela seus cinco reais e
10 reais fez muito bem para todas as
crianças do país de comprar cd comprar
logo se compro só mandamos fazer no
carro o jovem é gerante em campo keith
só que eu tenho um bairro chamado de
timing é de me sentir uma pessoa tão
respeitado me chamando de tinha um pai
de família que me sentindo assim uma
pessoa que tentava dar um salário mínimo
estão limitando meus que ele ainda tinha
que pagar a escola dele estava no ataque
e é bom nós fazer por vocês aí também no
cenário
a ecosul querer falar o que importa não
gente pode ser católica e evangélica
está teu de ofunato ajudando ajudando as
pessoas já tá bom demais e mulheres
galera que tem um grupo sorriso de anjo
que ajuda e sempre a todos veneno nas
outros casos em show nesta não é a gente
já foi ao hospital e é bacana disse que
sim mas é isso aí obrigado que você vai
gostar desse vídeo já dava aquele gostei
vinho entre na rua novo quadro
profissional e eu quero que você não
quer saber agora que você comente aqui
embaixo
qual foi a boa ação que você fez esse
ano foi a barração espécie nenhuma vamos
tratar de fazer é isso aí valeu valeu
hanói hanói no hot lanche